Now back to our discussion of the Spring
system at Sun. There is always a quadrum
of how to innovate in the operating system.
Academia is ripe for pursuing ideas that are
on the lunatic French but, if you are
an industry, you are always worried about, should
we do a brand new operating system? Or
do a better implementation of a known operating system.
Research industry is usually constrained by the
market place that it serves, specifically if you're
a company like Sun Microsystems; which in
its heydays, between 1980 and the 2005, it
was making Unix workstations. And it was
building large complex server systems which run 24/7
for a variety of applications, such as
airline reservation and so on and so forth.
And if you are in that marketplace, the
question becomes should we build a brand new
operating system or build a better implementation of
a known operating system? Marketplace demand says that, well,
there are legacy applications that are running on
your current operating system and therefore building a brand
new operating system may not be that viable
in an industrial setting. So the approach they took
in the Spring system at Sun Microsystems, is to be different but innovate where
it makes sense. And, it is a sort of like the, you may have seen commercials
that says, Intel inside, and the idea
is in processor architecture, Intel is dominant and
a lot of interesting computer architecture research
happens in innovating under the covers in the
micro architecture. So the external interface is
still well known interface like the Intel processor
but underneath they do a lot of innovation
in the micro architecture. In a similar manner,
if you are a company like Sun Microsystems
that peddles Unix boxes and you want to retain
your customer base, then you want to make sure
that the external interface remains UNIX and external
interface remains as UNIX. But under the covers,
you innovate where it makes sense. And in particular,
you want to make sure that everything that you
do in the operating system allows third party vendors,
to develop software against the new APIs that you
may provide in the operating system and integrate that
into operating system. While at the same time, making
sure that such integration is not going to break anything.
Or said differently, you want to preserve all the things
that are good in standard operating system, but at the
same time you want to make sure that the innovation
allows extensibility, flexibility and so on. That's sort of the
approach that Spring system took and for all the things
that I just said, using object orientation is a good
choice in order to make sure that we can do
innovation under the covers, while keeping the external interface the same.